spero mese sta ballando attenta tutto
tutto bene sono oggi giocheremo un nuovo
gioco e cioè andremo nell'ascensore con
tutti cantini che avete chiesto in
tantissimi di fare questo giorno
dell'ascensore in cui bisogna entrare
nell'ascensore ogni piano c'è un cattivo
diverso e bisogna sopravvivere a più
piani possibile chi fa più paura senza
basato per divertente noi vincerò io ho
vincerà vitale scrivetelo nei commenti e
poi vediamo alla fine chi ha indovinato
non devo saltare cadere delle cose voi
dovrebbe essere che vinco anch'io
potrebbe una seconda parte della sensore
pauroso non mi piace qui sotto se questo
video reso di 10 mila mi piace ci sarà
anche una seconda parte della sensore e
non seguite un cronista che ammontati a
seguirmi mettetevi comodi prendere i pop
corn
il gioco allora mi faccio vedere il mio
nome si ma sopratutto guardate le mie
ali non mi piacciono le colorate poi ho
degli stivali bianchi e un vestitino
bianco con una collanina bianca io adoro
troppo invece vita fino al 20 ha
cambiato la maglietta io faccio un
colore iolanda provato e si chiama
maglietta celestino questo è un momento
ma tutte in mutande soprattutto questo
lo avete scritto voi nei commenti
perché vitale scalzo scarpe gli stivali
color carne
allora iniziamo il loro gioco
innanzitutto esploriamo qua qua allora
dice che i cattivi facili sono questi
tra cui un gatto che sei cattini mesi
sono questi e già ne conosciamo qualcuno
di questi tipo ben di il pagliaccio
molti non so chi siano ma ce lo
scriverete voi perché voi sapete tutto
15 scriverete voi chi sono questi
cattivi invece a quelli difficili sono
bar di cartongesso
anche quando di fight night 3d comunque
siamo pronti un guarda qua sono qua
questi 41 sono alcuni cattivi ogni
livello ci sarà un cattivo lui
sopravvive per più livelli vince perché
si accumulano i punti siamo pronti
ecco l'assessore entriamo fa per dire a
soli 29 c'è un sacco di ci sono un sacco
ecco di altri giocatori e in genere le
borse si nascondono passo provvisto lei
anche i parà si nascondono povero non
essere presi dal cattivo però secondo me
che divertente proprio uscire dalla
sensore crisi sopravvivere così qua
allora chi sarà il cattivo qua
in pratica ogni piano bisogna scoprirlo
checa ha forse quello di file nei set
freddi scordati possono che cos'è rapidi
pd però tipo diversa io accendo la luce
vediamo ma c'è solo estremo qui sotto
guarda ci sono lucio è un cattivo rimane
lì sta per ripartire l'ascensore
io sono entrato qui dentro come prodotto
né voglio toccarlo
no penso che quello sia un personaggio
negativo
vabbè questo primo piano è fatto museo
set siamo arrivati dove sono finito
andiamo perché i gialli non lo so ho
fatto per farci mai la giochi prossimo
piano che farò il cattivo tutto rosso si
è siamo siamo nella navicella semina
mongardi il fasto raggiungere queste
cose prendete così o momento liturgici
loro per aruba paura ecco cattivo
l'impostore
scappa non ricorrendo qualcuno aiuto
eccolo lo vedi ma profondo parte
l'ascensore o eliminato qualcuno
poverino beh dai star importanti nel
settore succede se rimani fuori dalla
sensore mentre la sensore riparte rimane
per sempre bloccato con il cattivo mi
sai che lo scopriremo presto
sicuramente mi distrarrò rimarrò
bloccato gli stipendi mattina perché non
è eni e venite anche voi aiuto tipo dei
fantasmi sembrano brano di persone
ma dopo i tanti i wish to the uscito
dalla finestra l'immagine ed era vedi
qua dice che il cammino ogni volta del
nero forse perché non si vedeva perché
appunto era un fantasma incredibile
finora siamo sopravvissuti quanti piani
programmi di aiuto ci siete non lo so
che ci sono della scala e sta salendo su
grazia aiuto dobbiamo scendere quaggiù
non so dove sei aiuto ma dov'è il
cattivo non lo vedo
boh si sente un rumore strano qualcuno
sta ridendo io so tutto io vado a salire
la scala e tu dove sei
io sono più vedi vitale tranquilli al
sacco paura quando sei super tranquillo
va bene prendo le volete anch'io sono
scappato ho finito abbiamo sopravvissuto
neanche visto il cattivo wow per ora sta
andando bene credo fosse perché si
sentiva dire ne è su questo che io
questo cattivo noi però mi piace perché
siamo la padella in testa
e così siamo siamo arrivati il vino è
bello che sostanza saliamo su questo ma
dov'è non lo so dirlo colpo volete è in
rete
e così si aiuta è visto già in eccesso
nella fortuna per un fallo se abbiamo
fatto a chi sarà il prossimo
sam in una scuola a scuola sai chi può
essere una scuola chiesa oppure baldi è
mai visto né no perché volta porta si
muove da sola inquietante scivolo
affatto piaciuto perché balli di gruppo
io mi occupo pezzi baldi ha sempre
tenuto tutto bravo bravo quindi sei
stato eliminato si barrica presa a
matrix che brava si sopravvissuta
non lo so
riproviamoci tech primo piano siamo
tornati al primo piano ti amo tanto
volevo prendere qualche moneta bau
cambiato idea perché vorrei fare è
d'aiuto
non lo so non lo so io sto girando in
troppo sì c'è tipo lascia che per lei sa
che io sono quindi tutti rimasto nella
sessione
no io sto raccogliendo le monete ok io
provo a risalire magari riesco
raggiungermi vieni qua ma tu sei quando
si si si
l'occasione lo stesso ascensore comunque
è stato veramente inquietante quello
questa pete chi era come si chiamava
ambo lo faceva paurissima però la terra
siamo nello spazio ma che succede
non possiamo fare siamo siamo nello
spazio si è cosa dobbiamo fare
non so dobbiamo buttarci no anche se
salti vedi non puoi stare sulle persone
attivo disse che il cattivo e tipo una
radiazione piccolo vedevo che mi sono
nascondendo l'associazione arrivato
controsenso nominato qualcuno è visto ok
ok ha colpito solo una parola prossimo
guardia
non lo conosco
chi è questo che si sta aprendo qua io
racconto di ponente e tutto rosso che è
successo non lo so forse conosceva ma
dietro di me mano un coltello a 130 dove
sei
non lo so sono un signore è stato
eliminato qualcuno mi sa di ritorno in
ascensore ok ci siano sopravvissuti
anche questo piano strano rossi coppia
che aiuti tutti non solo 12 si sono
salvati ok abbiamo imparato una cosa
bisogna stare lontani da circo ma cosa è
un orso il pagliaccio cattivo il
pagliaccio cattivo scappa scappa scappa
torniamo a proporre salito nella ruota
hai visto che il pagliaccio l'ha
inseguito fino alla ruffino somma alla
ruota
aiuto io sono qua sopra
a parte sono indietro no c'è dietro che
pongono che appunto pongono anche la
musichetta è molto inquietante
tra sei vista brutta stavamo lì dietro
di te chi è il cattivo qua non capisco
c'è un muro blu corretto c'è qualcuno là
dei tre mesi una rotta che cos'è un
aiuto aiuto
no no no mentre anch'io qua dentro
tra tutti a terra su porcari non fa
paura fa paura ma spara eccoci comunque
abbiamo fatto un sacco di punti finora è
viva penso che sia pighi guardarono papi
rumore di pighi dov'è non ho visto qui
su una mensola tanti per prendere campo
strana tipo e mezzo fantasma parlando ha
chiuso qualcuno prigione in attesa anche
aiuto sto scappando sbaglio sei sopra la
testa di chi come bloccato non lo so
cos'è in fondo si può andare guarda
serio sta ballando
[Musica]
non capisco che strano ma non possiamo
certo dobbiamo vederci lo spettacolo di
usare né ballerino non mi ha colpito
come ti ha colpito guardo vedo che ha
attirato una banale visto wow è super
paura labirinto con le ragnatele sento
un rumore strano ci sono telecamere
inquietante ma io so se tutto migliore
di tubi mi stanno rubando tutte le
monete cattivo chi è o no senso che si
sta avvicinando c'è la torcia in istato
asi e ha fissato la torcia adesso mi
hanno colpito e tu vecchie non lo so
come ho fatto a pezzi
no mai visto che cos'è eravamo affatto
il tempo saprà vissuto e vive a faccia
non ci sei
presumendo è tornato proprio pulite o
leone in vantaggio io a 3050 punti
evitare nel 1900 yen
siamo find my friends aiuto ho rapporti
prendete con il burro e tipo una festa
di compleanno vita voli che bello quando
si mangia il cattivo forse ma non c'è
nessuno che si rincorre forse strano che
sta ballando ciao è forse sta arrivano
adesso negativo le luci più stanno
accendendo e spegnendo il primo
pomeriggio blu che fa io stavo mi
dispiace ma io non ho preso di nuovo a
per fortuna sono ritornato non solo il
coniglio bruno vedete non meno bravi
dentro la sua storia infatti mi nascondo
prima lettera difficili pericoloso anche
lei proviamo per l'ultima volta e
vediamo che sia tipici capita è che
circola tra i simpson si guarda c o
merli sull'amaca vicino all'albero che
testa grande arrabbiato nota perché lui
mi ha colpito accetta anche colpito
homer mai a mo di esplorare tutta la
casa ma no io voglio ritornare subito lì
ho qua c'è un buco nero attento e voglio
stati nessuna le camere di lisa e bart
non è mai uguale mai attenta lui e qua
fuori e sto cercando di imparare
io voglio andare per le altre cose ok io
sono troppo
e bello forse questa la camera divisa
grilli vieni qui questa camera di
l'isola madre di maggie
no ma chi è cattivo quindi era homer è
sì perché mi ama mi ha colpito con mazze
da baseball e chi è questo aiuto prima
cosa stiamo peggio il bello è che
cambiano sempre a torino musicante
gigante inquietante che un po dietro
rossi nasconditi cos'era quello lì che è
apparso del piccolo e grande come mamma
mia
aiuto è rimasto incastrato
una vera festa ios campo io scappo di e
velocissimo cartoon cat seppe nome
appreso riguarda o no queste questa
musichetta inquieta molto porosa chi è
cattiva mi ha preso businessman il
rientro un sensore subito lo avete visto
inquietante non mi ha preso di nuovo
quante volte è morso vitale in questo
senso
eccoci qua chi sarà il prossimo cattivo
ma dove stiamo che cos'è musica strano
dice entrata
io sto raccogliendo un po di monetine
[Musica]
non ho visto niente
quest'anno scappando tutti i giochi che
bello quindi forte il cattivo qua non
malato trasfondere tante abbaiando ma
che cos'è ricorda qualcuno
di qui ma un cane non può essere un
cattivo vediamo che carino ma chi non fa
niente vedi che io lino ieri che il
processo terminato
l'altalena anch'io all'altalena io sto
facendo qui su questa scivolo gigante
vediamo se cirsi che bello poi scivolare
visto o no sono rimasto così allora era
attentissimo questo da cercami con noi
guarda rientrato con noi sulle cariche o
no devi salire
devi salire tono cagata non sono che
porta sono caduta misura costa dove sono
verità questa cosa che a me no quanti
punti abbiamo fatto io l'avrei mila e
600 punti ed olio 2765 nidi o mentre
scritto vincerà vita però ligato
scriveteci qual è stato secondo voi il
cattivo più pauroso secondo me cartoon
cat e il pagliaccio e secondo secondo me
è quest'ultimo è anche quello lì che ha
chiuso l'occhio ha distrutto tutti
quanti secondo voi mi raccomando
lasciate un mi piace
ecco il cast la somma di queste 4 kasami
la linea per vedere i nostri altri video
dedicata su quella che preferite